Oh
the one thing that impresses me every
time I go into the sea and it should
impress everyone is the abundance of
life the ocean is not just rocks and
water from the surface that looks pretty
much the same everywhere you go
sometimes it's a little bluer door
greeter or grayer than others but most
people I think have the impression that
it's all about water and water of course
is the key to life it's a single
non-negotiable thing that life requires
but because most of Earth's water is
ocean you kind of expect that's where
most of life will be in and that's
that's the fact that is the way it is
dive into the ocean there's life all the
way down it's like diving into the
history of life on Earth to look around
when you're in the sea because you see
not just our fellow vertebrates so there
are plenty of them the fish in some
cases you have lucky encounters with
whales or dolphins you might see turtles
fellow vertebrates you might even see if
you're in the Galapagos Islands iguanas
fellow vertebrates but the great sweep
of life is mostly not about vertebrates
it's about the in vertebrates creatures
without backbones starting with a little
tiny things the microbes that rule the
world they were in the ocean in
abundance long before there were
organisms that had multi cellular
structure so having a chance to dive in
and to be aware even though you can't
see them you know that you're surrounded
by this is great sweep of tiny things
that generate much of the oxygen that
grabbed much of the carbon out of the
atmosphere the photosynthetic bacteria
and other forms of photosynthetic life
that are in abundance in plankton you
can't really see them for the most part
unless you have high magnification and
divers usually just have a face mask you
might see that the water is a little
greener
or not sometimes you can actually see
little particles but those are
relatively large compared to those so
the really tiny things that even with a
closest look you can deliver with your
eyes you really can't see the bacteria
that are there in great abundance and in
just a you know a cup of water you may
have millions of bacteria you may have a
thousand different kinds of these little
microbes it looks like water but it's
still filled with life and of course
there are the bigger things if you're
down on the bottom you might see sponges
they've been around for hundreds of
millions of years 400 500 million years
you might see starfish there are ancient
citizens to that go back 500 million
years you might see jellyfish pulsing by
think about 500 million years half a
billion years then you see some other
creatures that have taken a little
longer to form in terms of looking at
the history of life on Earth horseshoe
crabs have a history that goes back
perhaps as much as 400 million years but
other arthropods creatures that have
jointed legs crabs horseshoe crabs
aren't true crabs they're clip more
closely related to spiders and scorpions
even though they're out there in the
ocean but crabs and shrimp and little
copepods that feed on the algae the plot
of synthetic things that form the basis
of much of the great food chains food
webs in the ocean all of that surrounds
you is you dive in you see creatures
whose history preceded that of certainly
humankind or anything closely related to
us maybe sharks or they have a backbone
or back kartal each anyway that have a
history that goes back at least 300
million years we are really newcomers
our history is may be contained within
the last five million years
or anything like human civilization
think about 50,000 years or early when
you think about civilization with
language and art and things that we
really associate with who we think we
are maybe the last 10,000 years since
the end of the last ice age that's
nothing in the history of the earth or
life on Earth as a diver you can you can
think of yourself as almost an alien a
newcomer on this ancient planet filled
with creatures whose life preceded that
of humankind by hundreds of millions of
years